a federal judge just unloads on Bob
Muller's legal team suggesting that
they're lying and only out to get Trump
ha does that sound familiar district
judge TS Ellis is hearing the case
against former Trump campaign manager
Paul Manafort in the Eastern District of
Virginia and in court today he blasted
the special counsels legal team
questioning their motives and even their
honesty Ellis told prosecutors you don't
really care about Mr Man afford you
really care about what information mr.
Man afford can give you to lead you to
mr. Trump and an impeachment or whatever
the judge demanded to see the so-called
scope memo outlining the range of
Muller's Russia probe and when
prosecutors objected it his unrelated
material Ellis retorted I'll be the
judge of that
and then he added we don't want anyone
in this country with unfettered power
it's unlikely you're going to persuade
me the special prosecutor has the power
to do anything he or she wants the
American people feel pretty strongly
that no one has unfettered power well a
delighted president Trump broke news of
the hearing to the NRA annual meeting in
Dallas this afternoon a highly respected
judge in Virginia made statements it
says Wall Street Journal it says Judge
questions Mullins authority to prosecute
metaphore judge Thiele who was really
something very special I hear from many
standpoints he's a rich person suggested
the charges before the US District Court
for the Eastern District of Virginia
were just part of the Muller team's
designed to pressure mr. Madoff or into
giving up information on President
Trump port welcomes in the campaign I've
been saying that for a long time to
which on well let's review these
developments with house Intel committee
chairman Devin Nunez we have a lot to
talk about with him chairman Nunez it's
good to see you
ts Ellis I know very well he is a senior
judge in the Eastern District of
Virginia a long time ago I interviewed
with him I think I even argued a case
before him at one point very
well-respected appointed by President
Reagan back in 1987 but he was brutal on
the the council who was arguing the case
Michael Dreeben who is the basically a
Deputy Solicitor General who's now in
the Muller Office what were your
thoughts on his comments about how this
is really outside the scope of the
Muller Authority I was astonished by the
comments the judge made today although
it's not surprising everything in this
case Laura has just gone off the rails
there's not a day that goes by that
something new crazy doesn't break you
know finally just today we were able to
get the two pages that we needed that we
now know that Comey and McCabe did in
fact say that general Flynn
you know the agents the interview
general Flynn didn't think he was lying
now we listened to mr. Comey over the
last three weeks run around saying just
the opposite so you have the judge
saying that they're lying the Moller
teams lying you now have the case where
we now know that mr. Comey has been
lying out there publicly this continues
to just I think that's been will during
quite frankly now Congressman Jim Comey
basically decided to override the agents
including Peter struck who you know we
focus on Struck's
techs with Lisa page and maybe as an
animus against President Trump but I
believe unless I'm wrong I believe
Peters struck with one of the agents who
interviewed Mike Flynn and we had heard
this from some time now confirmed that
Mike Flynn didn't lie Lisa it was up to
them meaning port Mike Flynn they had to
twisted the screws on him to plead
guilty to a false statement in order to
you know like a lot of people do save
their
family save their whatever money they
have left and and meanwhile commis going
around saying no no no he lied and this
is you know it's it's wild why wouldn't
you be override the age this is my
question well well look this isn't new
news to us on the Intelligence Committee
this has been the problem of all these
issues that they keep classified from
the American people so we knew this very
shortly after the interview took place
mister the interview where the FBI
agents went into the White House and
interviewed mr. Flynn shortly after that
mr. Comey comes in briefs us that's on
the record I know he also briefed other
committees so on the record we knew what
mr. Comey said we had the transcripts we
have been fighting with the Department
of Justice and the FBI for six weeks to
release this information to the American
people we finally have it tonight late
on a Friday night this is totally
unacceptable you have the judge from
this morning this has just continued
ridiculous behavior it's like they just
want to keep digging and the American
people are beginning to understand that
the Department of Justice and the FBI
have major problems I have no idea how
they can investigate themselves but
evidently they continue to believe they
can but they have so many more documents
that they have to provide to us that we
that we needed like yesterday and I hate
to have to continue to come out publicly
and talk about this that we are still
yeah let's remind everyone a few weeks
ago you were on the show I believe it
was a Friday night if my memory serves
me correct maybe it was a Thursday night
and you essentially threatened rod
Rosenstein with contempt of Congress or
impeachment
if the underlying document the computer
document that authorized the probe of
the spying on Carter page surveillance
on Carter page wasn't released he did
finally then release that congressman
Nunez however now you're getting slammed
in response by CNN and now others that
you are asked for these documents and
then you Devon una
have a staffer read them you don't read
them so how serious are you you just
want to help the president you're not
even reading the documents what about
that CNN report that came out today yeah
so look I I enjoy being attacked the
first thing I will tell you is whatever
CNN in The New York Times are write or
talk about I don't read their
information I will tell you that we're
not going to get into the specifics
about how we conduct our investigation
but I will tell you Laura and I've said
this numerous times on your show and
others is that mr. Gowdy our lead
investigator mr. Gowdy is the one who
reviews all the initial documents with
our investigators I'm not going to get
into the processes that we use but as
the chairman of the committee when they
need documents they come to me we use
the power that we have vested in us by
the Constitution to try to force the
Department of Justice and the FBI to
comply no but you can see the criticism
yeah I'm trying to help our viewers
understand this though when you're when
they come after you and say Nunez is is
getting getting these documents I think
a lot of people want you to have these
documents then you don't read them it
opens you up to criticism so I mean I
don't understand why it compromises the
investigation for you to say
I read the documents that are necessary
to do this investigation and I consult
with my staff on the you know on the
primary documents but I read those so I
don't understand why your reluctance to
say whether you read them or don't read
them I don't get that well look this is
first of all what they're talking about
there in that is is that it's a page and
a half what what specifically we were
looking for in that as you may remember
as we are looking we're investigating
the State Department we are looking for
any official intelligence that came
across through the five eyes channels
that's what we were looking for that was
not in the document so at that point at
this point we have other lines of
inquiry that we're going down
we have subpoena out there and so you
know this is this is why you know we can
play process games all the time but at
the alt a long but at the end of the day
here yeah you know we continue to have
our investigation blocked we can't have
to deal with a missing from
disinformation campaign
well I'm a and this is what the left
always does just so I mean everyone who
watches this show understands because
they've done it to me they've tried to
when you're effective and when you're
holding people accountable and if you
are conservative or if you've ever
supported the president you are a target
and so that's why you know all the
articles floating around about you and
Paul Ryan should take you off the
committee that was a couple of weeks ago
it's it's predictable I want to read for
you a comment by Eric Lichtblau about
what's happened to the FBI he said many
view Trump's attacks as self-serving
he's called the renowned agency an
embarrassment to our country and its
investigations of its business and
political dealings as a witch-hunt
but as much as the bureau's roughly
fourteen thousand special agents might
like to tune out the news internal and
external reports have found lapses
throughout the agency and longtime
observers looking past the partisan haze
see a troubling picture something really
is wrong at the FBI now that's not Devon
Nunez saying that that is a Lichtblau
sang it yeah this is what I've I've
actually conveyed this to director Ray
he has a tough tough job to do he needs
to clean the place up I've said this
also publicly there we don't see a
systemic problem out in the field with
filled agents or with people overseas
that are doing very difficult work
trying to track down terrorists and
other bad guys where we do see a problem
is in Washington DC now - director Ray's
credit you have seen many of the Comey
era people have been excused that's a
good sign
it would be even better is if director
ray made sure that we get this
information that we need in a timely
manner congressman thank you so much for
joining us tonight we really appreciate
it